at first this looks like a perfectly
normal map of New York City zoom in and
there's Broadway and Bowery but then you
realize that the map is wrong streets
run diagonally and the map ads land
beyond the edge of the island that's
because this wasn't a map it was a plan
that was rejected in this one the one
with the perfect grid we know was
basically what we ended up with today
Manhattan has a grid so perfect that the
way the Sun shines through it is a
hashtag on Instagram
but these grits were not all about
beautiful design or even making it
easier to find your direction when you
come up out of the subway
the real reason one of these plans made
it and the other didn't it says
something about how and why cities
develop the way they do this is a utopia
called Philadelphia when William Penn
designed Philadelphia in 1681 he wanted
to make an ideal city his intentions
reflected American ideas and his
Quakerism the lines on his grid weren't
just right angles they were morally
right angles he wanted to preserve a
sense of a country town using common
areas and gardens in 1733 in Savannah
Georgia
the Oglethorpe plan was influenced by
the Enlightenment with an emphasis on
balance and limits on the grids growth
that resulted in a grid - but with an
elegant design including common squares
where all could congregate in Commons
limiting the grid plans reach Pierre
L'Enfant 1791 plan for Washington DC was
even more ambitious and though the city
deviated from his design some flourishes
survived like diagonal avenues sliced
across the city circles to vary the
grid's monotony and grand squares for
each of the then 15 states New York was
never so organized this 1767 map shows
the chaotic curve streets and
irregularities that marked the nearly
150 years of European settlement when
little order that had developed was
largely private and subject to frequent
change this 1776 map shows a planned
grid with a large square that square
belongs to the Delancey estate Delaney
was a typo because the prominent New
York family supported the British during
the Revolutionary War the city
confiscated their land after the war the
1789 map shows what happened to their
planned square it disappeared New York
could have been stuck with this chaos
but as the 1800s rolled around it
couldn't afford to be much longer it's
tough to know New York's exact
population
before 1800 but the trend was clear
massive growth more than doubling
between 1770 and 1790 outbreaks of
yellow fever that spread up and down the
East Coast heightened the urgency to
build a cleaner more orderly City and
that is where this failed plant comes in
in 1797 the city hired architect Joseph
Mangin and surveyor Casimir Kirk to map
New York the plan showed the city as it
should be not as it was they widened
Genki streets and even added to the
waterfront they proposed something
graceful but the city needed something
fast so their plan was rejected in 1807
the state established a new Commission
to create a workable plan and it was
huge in this map this color shows the
settled land and this color shows the
projected areas for the grid in their
official report they said they planned
for a greater population than is
collected at any spot on this side of
China the grid made sense to hold it
they debated whether they should confine
themselves to rectilinear and
rectangular streets or whether they
should adopt some of those supposed
improvements by circles ovals and stars
which certainly embellish a plan
whatever may be their effect as to
convenience and utility basically did
they want L'enfance Washington or a
uniform grid
they decided that right-angled houses
are the most cheap to build and the most
convenient to living the effect of these
plain and simple reflections was
decisive the grid did that without
screwing up existing property lines it
was predictable for developers this was
a different type of design the grid
seems orderly to us but this order was
in service of cheapness and efficiency
city needed to build to keep going what
could be more New York than that this
plan is in for a city but a Park Central
Park Landscape Architect Frederick
Olmstead designed that Park in many
other public spaces in a laundry list of
criticisms of the New York City grid he
said that still other and perhaps even
graver misfortunes to the city could
have been avoided by a different
arrangement of its streets and it's true
the dream plan would have been more
refined but this just wasn't practical
city plans reflect values and then they
shape culture in 1811 New York's values
were build build build so they adopted a
plan to do it
'don't development you just have the sun
the buildings make it worth looking at
[Music]
hey that's it for this episode about
grids I'm about to read some comments
from the previous episode of this
almanac roadtrip edition but it was all
about the vagabonds Edison was walking
around calling Harvey Firestone dude
yeah he was and also one thing that I
was able to mention was that Edison was
really hard of hearing at this time in
his life so basically every time you
wanted to talk to him
you had to yell directly into his ear a
20-19 version would probably be in a
Tesla with Elon Musk Bill Gates and
Warren Buffett and Leonardo DiCaprio I
will see you next week and I'm actually
going to be driving in this episode so
get ready and buckle up
[Music]
you